hi everyone uh andy richter here uh
podcasting yet again i'm actually in uh
the uh
uh conan o'brien memorial studio oh no
what happened
well i don't know he's just not here
today so it's memorial we have to we
have to think about him in the past
tense um
and i want to tell you this one today is
not going to pass the bechdel test
because we are talking about conan all
the time
don't know we are tired i'm kidding no
i'm kidding because we're not really
gonna um but you know i mean because he
might be more boring to the two of us
than to anyone else i know that's the
baby is family no absolutely that's the
thing and i do feel like uh by the way
i'm uh talking to liza powell o'brien uh
who's here today to promote both her new
podcast
and her play oh isn't it well it's
that's over but we can talk about it
what i mean isn't it gonna play and
you're not going to it's not going to
run anywhere else listen if anyone out
there would like to produce it please
contact me well i would but i'm broke
because somebody show end it
oh is that what happened yeah that's
what happened no wonder um it is
tempting to oh you said oh about him
being boring right yeah to other people
yeah it is
i do feel in many ways
like i'm his tv wife you're his real
life wife and i'm his tv wife
um because
being with him
for all those years
definitely gave me
like it made me
very sympathetic
towards the things that my ex-wife would
go through
at parties or out in the world
of just kind of
all this attention being on me and then
her kind of like oh hi you know to her
and then me me me me and there would
there that would happen it would
it was just i mean first of all he's a
parade float he can't be incognito you
know that one time
he i think he's talked about this but we
were in seattle in the winter where it
gets dark at four o'clock in the
afternoon yeah and he would take these
obsessively long bike rides in the dark
in the rain
maybe to escape my family
maybe to porno shops
definitely um and he was once um on the
bike with the helmet and like you know
glasses so that the rain didn't get in
his eyes and it was dark and he was
maybe 50 yards away from a car and he
thought well now i'll be you know yeah
anonymous
hey conan like people driving by just he
is instantly yeah i don't know what it
is a ski helmet
he is and yeah and especially without a
hat on then he's really i forgot that
but there were so many people that used
to like he if he and i are out in the
world
come up and say i love the show i watch
it all the time can i get a picture with
you and then okay and then just like
hand the camera to me and you are yeah
and i'd be like
i mean in some ways i understand it
because i just
i can understand like the weird having
experienced people
meeting me and think and saying you're
andy dick
and like my god well i'm being like
what what how do you get i mean
and then really it's just something with
the name but then sometimes they really
do think like you're andy dick you were
on the ben stiller show or whatever you
know like i don't and you're wrong if
you try and controvert that right you're
like actually no they're like
they're just well sometimes yeah
sometimes they're weird that way but
other times it's just
the synapses get all screwed up because
they get excited so i never took offense
to it and also
i i'm fine with
not a lot of attention so i mean and is
that is that something you've i mean
are you fine with not a lot of attention
yeah i don't know what to do
the first time that i went to the emmys
with him
in 2000 i was so nervous about being
scrutinized
because i'd never been in any kind of
public view at all
and i
got out of the car was this when you're
just dating you're just engaged or just
no no just dating you've been dating
like four months yeah or something i
don't know six months something like
that and um you get out of the car
and there's that gauntlet of all the
stands of the people screaming and
i mean i haven't been in a long time i
don't know if it's changed but um you
know yeah they're on bleachers they're
on bleachers and they're in the hot sun
and they're making a lot of noise and
the photographers and all the handlers
and i instantly realized oh i could
burst into flame and not only would
nobody notice yeah they certainly would
not put me out right like
i am so beside the point here and it was
actually a great relief because i oh you
know when people say like what's you
what superpower would you love to have i
always wanted to be invisible like that
would have made me feel so comfortable
yeah yeah um and i was tall early so i
was not usually invisible um and uh so
so in some ways like he's my
invisibility cloak which i love yeah so
i feel much less self-conscious right
right around him well tell me about uh
the new podcast um the new podcast is
what's it called it's called significant
others
and it's historical and um which is
right on brand for team coco it is not
comedic uh well but they need to branch
out too you know sure why not you know
stretch the brand a little um i i'm
feeling badly though for the people who
like just followed because it was a team
coco property and then we're like what
when's it gonna get funny but anyway
yeah so um
it is telling stories of people who have
been sort of overlooked historically
like um
especially
um people who were closely related to
someone who was of significance so
um varana bokov for example who um
saved the manuscript of lolita from the
trash from the her husband was going to
burn it twice wow and she was like no no
no we're keeping that and she was
massively important in his life overall
um and they have a fascinating story so
or mary lincoln i think is out uh next
and um that was actually conan's
suggestion because
um and i was like i mean everybody knows
mary lincoln and yeah she's cuckoo right
and i was like no but she was actually
really formative for him in the early
years they were they were quite a like
he may not have been president if he
hadn't been married
yeah so and she had a lot of connections
to the south which helped him so
um so it's just eight episodes this
season um they're all along those lines
not all spouses not all um you know
stories of
the woman behind the man i didn't want
it to fall into that sure trope
you know we're uh revealing that this
person's actually secretly been an
[ __ ] all this time like there's some
elements of that sure because you can't
avoid it but that's not the point of it
right well it can be very fun so
so yeah that's it and we have
um great people who are voicing the the
subjects for us like nick and megan did
the toll stories nick offerman and megan
yep and uh
dan pukatinsky did uh um vladimir pokov
and darcy cardin does verona oh wow and
lisa kudrow does elliot kazan's wife um
so and there's some other fun jack
mcbrears in there a little bit you know
really great
um people were very lucky to have so
many lovely friends i'm taking all the
friends that conan has needed and then
gained yes over all this time and and
just using them yes essentially whatever
that's that's the world
i love leaving the house these days so
we can do it over soon
can we do it here
here yeah let me get out of the house
uh well that's great and is it i mean
how long does each episode take you to
write and how are they half hours are
the hours or the episodes are between 30
40 minutes yeah and then the five the
sweet spot yeah yeah that's the and then
the follow-up episode is usually 25 20
25. um and
i don't even know how long they take me
to write because they take me so long to
write it is i thought when i first
talked to adam sax about doing this um
i thought you know six months to do them
all maybe nine if i'm really going to be
persnickety that was a year and a half
ago
it it has been
um a bit of a hair shirt but all of my
own making so yeah yeah it takes they're
very labor-intensive yeah that's why i
like this podcast is just chatting
because i can't
i just homework like why would i sign on
for homework i literally like i have
assigned myself eight essays yeah long
form essays that for no class no degree
nobody's ever gonna care and uh why am i
doing this i don't know yeah you gotta
do something you do gotta do something
yeah
you